taking a page out of Kellyanne Bowling
Green Massacre Conway's playbook Donald
Trump said yesterday brace yourself
strap in folks that the United States
murder rate is the highest it has been
in 47 years this is of course false it's
part of the narrative that things are
more dangerous than ever in the United
States the reality is violent crime has
been on the decline in the United States
and around the world for decades extreme
poverty has been on the decline
worldwide for decades the percentage of
the world's population living in the
midst of wars has been on the decline
for decades and as usual sort of
implicit in Donald Trump's fake data is
that it's because of the media that you
haven't heard about this reality which
Trump claims exist here's Trump speaking
about this yesterday and making this
totally bogus claim the murder rate in
our country is the highest has been in
47 years right and you know that 47
years I used to lose that I'd say that
in the speech and everybody was
surprised because the press doesn't tell
it like it is yeah it's like Groundhog's
Day over here the reason media didn't
cover Kellyanne Conway is bowling green
massacre was because it never happened
it didn't exist there was nothing to
cover and the reason that there's no
reporting on a 47 year high murder rate
is that it also doesn't exist there is
no 47 year high murder rate to cover
let's start with the murder rate chart
which as you can see here is near a
45-year lo dating back to nineteen
seventy the truth is not slightly
different when you look at this chart
than what Donald Trump said it's the
complete opposite of what Donald Trump
said and you can see at the end of the
chart there there's a little spike from
2014 to 2015 but the overall rate here
Rachel because I know that you're able
to see and interpret visually things
with your eyes clearly were not at a 45
year high are we know but this is a
strategy that works for him last year
when he put forth that tweet about the
fake murder of statistics from that
neo-nazi oh yeah the race to race based
murder data yeah yeah yeahs which was
absolutely huge he
leading in the field nine points after
that in a CBS poll right after said that
what Iowa residents liked most about him
was that he was willing to say what
other people wouldn't say so yeah seeing
that this works for him many times that
willingness exists only in Trump because
other people don't want to just
blatantly lie and make up statistics
violent crime by the way also way down
as I mentioned we have a graph of that
as well for people watching with us if
you look at violent crime hitting a peak
sort of in 1992 or so and a very very
steady decline and like Rachel said Pat
Trump repeatedly misstated these figures
during the campaign and continued to
make erroneous claims about how violent
the United States is right now and it
worked really well because people said
Wow things are really violent because
they didn't fact-check I guess that
means I should vote Trump because he's
telling it like it is and he didn't
think it was incumbent on him to
fact-check as well and I think the other
thing they got he got wrong here is that
even if the murder rate was at a 47-year
high the media would love to cover that
we have a sensational lyst media in this
country and they would be all over that
story yeah there's no real reason based
on our accurate understanding of
corporate media why corporate media
would hide that I mean if it bleeds it
leads we know about that we know about
the disproportionate cover coverage of
terror attacks perpetrated by Muslims
the disproportionately low coverage of
terrorist attacks perpetrated by white
American dudes we can probably bet that
if Trump destroys the economy and key
institutions of the US the violent crime
and murder rates will go up but that's
not where we are right now the Trump era
I used to call it solutions that don't
work for problems that don't exist
that's been my tagline for it Rachel I'm
expanding it now two solutions that
don't work for problems that don't exist
combined with projection and
self-fulfilling prophecies and that
seems to be sort of the calling card of
Trump if your significant other Pat lied
as much as Trump does you wouldn't stay
with them with you you'd say it's this
is emotional abuse it kind of goes back
to the conversation we had yesterday
about who could possibly be with
Kellyanne can progress he's speaking
like that you Kellyanne Bowling Green
massacre
way why is this important right it's not
just another lie from Trump if you
believe that the United States is way
more dangerous than it actually is
you're willing to tolerate or support
different policies based on that and a
perfect example is of the the post
terrorist support terrorist attack
support that we see for more
surveillance and more invasive spying by
government agencies so this is not just
another lie Rachel this really matters
no it's not another line I'm quite
frightened to see how throughout the
course of his presidency this kind of
negatively sways public opinion it could
be really dangerous absolutely i'm on
twitter at d pakman we are all on
twitter as a collective at david pakman
show send me your thoughts about what's
going on with Trump and his 47-year lies
today's show is brought to you by
godaddy where you can buy your own
domain name build a website or use any
of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save thirty percent at try godaddy.com
slash david go daddy has actually been
the official host of the david pakman
show website for many many many years
the 24 7 customer support has been a
very good thing for us i've called them
at really odd times when we've had
website issues and they are always
available they are the largest domain
registrar and whether you have a new
idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com slash david